在市场里最常见的一幕是这样的
交易者盯着屏幕
看着K线在均线附近来回震荡
终于全线出现金叉或死叉
或者价格突破了关键线
心里一阵亢奋
立刻下单
那一刻
他觉得自己不是在赌博
而是在执行规则
有依据有逻辑
可是帮忙不过几个小时
甚至几分钟
行情掉头
只准备少丈夫再次回到原位
为什么会这样
为什么看起来有逻辑的交易
结果却和盲目操作没有区别
如果我们把问题归结为运气不好
那就太轻描淡写了
真正需要追问的是
既然有一句
为什么一句不起作用
答案其实很残酷
均线本身没有问题
真正出问题的是人
大多数交易者并不是不会用均线
而是等不了在心理层面
这是一种典型的落差
你以为自己是按照逻辑行事
实际上只是借助均线来掩盖焦虑
明明是情绪驱动
却硬要披上一层技术外衣
让自己觉得这是规则
这是方法
换句话说
所谓均线交易很多时候并不是一种技术体系
而是一种心理安慰
也正因为有了这种心理安慰
才会出现一个悖论
越依赖均线交易反而越乱
这种现象并不少见
回顾多数人的交易轨迹
你会发现一个共性
他们最容易出手的时刻
往往不是信号真正成熟的时候
而是信号刚冒头的那一瞬间
因为那一刻能满足一个最直接的需求
终于有理由下单了
而问题正在这里
他们要的不是趋势
而是借口
均线的本质其实是趋势的数学抽象
它通过平滑价格波动
帮助交易者看清市场的整体方向
可一旦被用错
军衔就变成了情绪的放大器
越是短周期越容易让人产生某该出手的错觉
于是原本该让你冷静的工具
反而变成了催促你频繁操作的信号器
既然均线容易被误用
那就要回到源头
他到底在映射什么趋势
不是某一根K线的突破
不是均线的一次交叉
而是经过时间和空间的累积后
形成的结构性运动
换句话说
军事需要等待
需要验证
需要大局观
如果你只是把均线当做即时买卖的信号
那它必然会让你失望
所以均线的真正价值不在于
它告诉你什么时候买
而在于提醒你什么时候不该买
它最大的功能是帮助你
排除掉那些没有意义的小波动
让你明白了多是时候不动才是正确选择
这正是多数人和少数人之间的差别
多数人急于寻找机会
少数人则利用均线获利机会
然而大多数人偏偏走向了相反的方向
他们盯着5日
10日
20日的均线交叉
仿佛那就是通往利润的密码
可结果往往是信号频繁
交易混乱
账户逐渐缩水
等他们冷静下来复盘
才发现自己陷入了一个怪圈
越想找到逻辑
越容易被幻觉牵着走
这就是心理落差的根源
你以为自己在用规则
其实你在满足情绪
你以为军签能带来稳定
其实他只是给了你一个不断操作的理由
既然如此
唯一能打破这种落差的方法
就是重新安排居建在你系统中的位置
怎么做
关键在于重新鉴定均线的作用
第一步
让均线不再成为你频繁出手的借口
而是成为筛选行情的过滤器
第二步
用长周期均线确定大方向
只有当大趋势清晰
你才有资格考虑建仓
第三步
彻底放弃短线信号的追逐
不要再盯着每一次惊差时差
不要当随机波动当成机会
第四步
只在均线收敛扩张形成大结构的时候
才允许自己出手
那才是真正有意义的交易窗口
这套逻辑听起来简单
但真正能做到的人极少
因为它的核心要求是扫动
而少动现在是大多数交易者最缺乏的能力
他们习惯了追逐
习惯了不断验证存在感
却没有意识到真正的高手是靠等待来赢得
在这里你会发现一个耐人寻味的真相
真正的功夫不是找到多少机会
而是舍弃多少诱惑
等待不是被动
而是主动的选择
他要求你放弃短期的刺激
把注意力转移到结构的成熟上
黑要求你忍住一次次看似机会的诱惑
只把子弹留给真正值得的行情
他要求你在心理上承认市场不欠你交易机会
你也不需要明天证明自己
换个角度看
交易的分水岭就在这里
多数人把均线当做行动的理由
于是越做越乱
少数人把均线当做过滤器
于是越等越稳
这也是为什么
同样的指标在不同人手里
会呈现出完全相反的结果
均线的作用不是推动你加速
而是提醒你在该停的时候停下
真正的高手
不会因为一根均线的交叉就贸然进场
他们靠的是耐心
把仓位留给真正属于自己的行情
但你愿意用它来限制自己
而不是驱动自己
结果却完全不同
所以军线真正考验的不是你会不会看
而是你能不能忍
回到开头的问题
为什么很多人用均线越做越乱
因为他们误解了均线的意义
把它当成了出手的理由
而不是等待的数据
均线不是逻辑
更不是捷径
真正的逻辑在于
当长期周线没有方向
你唯一正确的动作就是静坐观望
当趋势真正成型
你才该出手
当你明白了这一点
军事才能真正成为你的帮手
不是让你多做
而是让你少做
不是给你信号
而是让你学会等待
只有这样
你的交易才会看似由依据变成真正有逻辑